[Music]
ever since I was a child people said my
family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing could
ever hurt
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please David
Carrie I want you to join your brothers
in the ring yes sir I love that now we
all know Carrie's my favorite then Kev
then David then Mike but the rankings
can always change what do you want in
life Kevin ER more ribs I want to be
with my family you know be with my
brothers what do you like to do with
your
brothers and
David
together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that will pass down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron claw to
you so what do you think like we're
liive I love your family
Kevin don't be an uncle yes sir oh man
that makes me so happy I talk to you
about something tomor D's too tough on
us you got to say something babbe that's
what your brothers are for you feel that
you feel that that's
pressure you're pushing too hard I'm F
GI seriously I'm just
sick God I'm scared man all my had of
control was a terrible accident I should
have stopped him I need to think about
my family your job is to wrestle live up
to that deal while we are through I told
going to look out for him I just love
being out there with you guys it's the
only thing that matters to me the will
forever be the greatest family in the
history of
[Applause]
[Music]
wrestl